tout nouveau smartphone de Motorola qui
vient de sortir c'est le S40 pro et le
S40 pro il est intéressant pourquoi
parce qu'au niveau du design l'écran est
incurvé sur les quatre côtés on a ici en
plus un très grand écran de
6,67 pouces et on va jusqu'à un taux de
rafraîchissement de 165 Hertz en plus de
ça l'écran est certifié 10 plus 1
milliard de couleur résolution Full HD+
autant vous dire qu'ici globalement ça
fera l'affaire ils vous ont mis un verre
quand on est Gorilla glace victus à
l'avant mais également à l'arrière et en
plus de ça on a une résistance à l'eau
et à la poussière il peut 68 un
smartphone qui ont plus de ça est très
performant avec le stade dragon 8 GN2 on
a 12 Go de RAM 256 Go de stockage une
grosse batterie de 4600 mAh et en plus
de ça une recharge très rapide de 125
watts alors bien évidemment il est pas
en reste en photo avec trois capteurs
grand angle ultra grand-angle et
téléobjectif il tourne bien évidemment
sur Android 13 et il est vendu au tarif
de 899 €, ici il y a pas d'augmentation
de tarif donc un smartphone à la fois
performant à la fois puissant avoir bien
évidemment plus tard lorsqu'on testera
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez marquez moi ça bien évidemment
dans les commentaires